all right surprising amount of requests
for me to talk about this one i feel
like this movie's kind of hit some
sort of not fandom divide not fandom war
but just kind of culture war in general
it's like you either
like this movie and with your team chris
pratt or you don't and with your team
hollywood and that sucks
what i i don't want to you know i talk
about trivial entertainment and not
religion and politics because
it's trivial entertainment not religion
and politics
but i guess entertainment's become
religion and politics so here we go
let's talk religion and politics i guess
[Music]
so the tomorrow war stars chris pratt
and it's a movie that
the concept is amazing when i explain it
here when you hear it explained
elsewhere you're like that's kind of
genius i want to see it chris pratt's
the next military guy he's a science
teacher now he's living that suburban
family life you know with all the
houses lined up together in a cul-de-sac
and
you know the sprinkler then on national
television a platoon of soldiers from
the future
show up through time and they're like
hey we're
losing this war against alien monsters
so we need more soldiers so we're going
to pull
soldiers from all of you in this time in
our past
because if we fail you don't have a
future so it only makes sense but when
you're going about time travel and
something like this you can go about it
a few different ways one there's one
linear timeline the future soldiers are
our future we are their past
if you change something in the past it
alters the future like back to the
future and marty mcfly disappearing
because his parents weren't gonna meet
or again there's one timeline but you
can't alter anything
whatever happened happened if you go to
the past and do something
that something that you did always
happened and you always went to the past
it's immutable
irredeemable unalterable kind of like
how daniel faraday and lost broke it
down or legacy of kane
another legacy of kane reference you
know i love legacy of kane or and this
is the one the movie actually does from
where i'm coming from and how i'm seeing
it people in the future can come to the
past and alter the past but it doesn't
alter that timeline that those people
from the future know is their presence
you can't just oh i want to win the
lottery
so i'm going to go back in time and give
myself winning lotto tickets no you just
create an alternate timeline where
there's a you who
got winning lotto tickets but your life
remains unchanged because
now it's two different timelines so both
timelines exist at that point our
present isn't necessarily the future's
past when it comes to these soldiers
fighting this war
which actually i really like like i like
it in concept
in this movie a lot of things in this
movie i like i like in concept i don't
think this movie really sticks the
landing all the time but that's a great
concept
the reason i think it's a great concept
for this movie is
that's kind of messed up it's very
selfish in the future they're running
low on soldiers because these monsters
are just tearing them up and then they
come to the past so like hey
we need you to fight because we're your
future though
not necessarily and they just kind of
wreck our
present and our path our timeline
because they need more soldiers and
millions of people die for their future
war they're just using us as cannon
fodder it's kind of messed up that's why
i think that's why they have this rule
where you don't fight in the future war
you don't fight in the tomorrow war
unless you're dead by that time the
reason they pitch is well that's
a paradox will happen but if you're
going on this concept of how this
movie's dealing with time
i think it's just to make themselves
feel better it's like well they were
going to die anyway so it doesn't really
matter again great concept but i don't
think the movie really stuck the landing
and illustrating that to the audience
and sometimes this movie looks like it
has a big budget it's like 200 million
dollar movie and sometimes you're like
that is a 200 million dollar movie all
right then other times you're like
where did that budget go because that's
some pretty shoddy cgi did it go to the
marvel star you got an mcu star in this
movie
they're expensive mcu stars they are
expensive when you first meet the
monsters i thought the intro to the
monsters was
top-notch they're in this really dark
dreary building and they look up
and this monster's there and it looks
down at them and it's all
super pale on the dark background it's
like
when you first meet them i was like it's
like the monsters
from a quiet place had the head of
azmodan from diablo 3. pretty terrifying
looking stuff and then they have these
tendrils that shoot spikes you're like i
get that they have a function
they start looking goofy and after that
monster introduction it's like the cgi
for the monsters got worse and worse as
the movie went on then by the end i'm
like that's a lot of just
cgi waves of monsters i suppose when it
had that survival horror tone
i loved it and then when it's just waves
of cgi monsters i was like i'm kind of
over it you can have great action movie
but still have survival horror tone
aliens i thought nailed it that's one of
the greatest action movies of all time
so i'm not expecting it to be that
caliber i'm just illustrating that you
can
do it it doesn't have to just be waves
of cgi monsters that start
boring you and that brings me to the
comic relief in this movie some of it
works some of it was just
really awkward with one character in
particular
who felt like he was plucked from a
comedy movie and plopped into this movie
which is something i throw out there and
people say oh people deflect with humor
and
intense situations and that is true
let's say we had the movie aliens and
jim carrey as ace ventura was in
aliens that wouldn't really mix it would
be too much comedy but bill paxton and
aliens i thought did work you know so at
a point you can go too far and in a
world of different kinds of comic relief
and maybe that's part of the problem
because they didn't they couldn't decide
what kind of comic relief they wanted
you have jk simmons and his bitter
boomer style of comic relief
i felt it did work also he plays chris
pratt's father and there is a family
dynamic in this movie that's a big part
of the movie there were some surprising
moments of heart in this movie with
chris pratt and i do appreciate that
because i like chris pratt but i was
surprised that he wasn't the comic
relief in the movie he actually has a
couple lines i was like that's just
it's kind of comic relief but it just
sounds like a real conversation but as
for the movie
where everything that i liked was in
concept and on paper but when you watch
it it just kind of comes across
as a generic sci-fi action movie just
one of those movies like i watched and i
was like alright that happens there's
this
thought on the internet it's like wait
are people bagging on this movie
because they don't like chris pratt
because he might be a republican and
he's most definitely a christian and in
a world where
hollywood is somehow perceived as the
cool kids table
in the high school cafeteria all that
about chris pratt isn't really a cool
kid's thing to be
at that table in the cafeteria so i can
kind of see it but again i don't know i
don't know if that's the case but
hollywood being
the elitist dicks that they are i could
see it being the case but in a world
where the internet can speculate for
days on whether or not with that
situation i will say
if hollywood or the entertainment
industry personally ever hate you
that just means you're probably doing
something right in life that's just the
way i see it benefit of the doubt i'd be
interested to see a sequel in this movie
if they can refine some of the concepts
get a better script you know they can
work it out that's what happened with
the purge the second purge movie is
actually a pretty good time
also benefit of the doubt i watched this
stone sober and maybe this movie
is a better time but if you're drunk
yeah now it's the tomorrow war is gonna
be the hangover that's for sure all
right so the tomorrow war have you seen
it what did you think about it whatever
you thought comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see
[Music]
more
you